Diane Feinstein the longest serving
female member of the US Senate had Di
has died at the age of 90 the California
Democrat who pushed bills on gun control
and the environment had been unwell and
planed to retire at the end of her term
next year well for more on this let's
speak to Patty khain who's in Washington
DC and uh as I mentioned there she had
been unwell for quite some time hadn't
she she had been and it really led to
calls uh a lot of people talking about
per perhaps it's time to put age limits
on members of Congress it's not just
Dian Feinstein it was Mitch McConnell
who has been freezing on camera there
are of course questions about Joe
Biden's age as he runs for re-election
as well as Donald Trump uh but no she
was sick she was had shingles was in the
hospital uh for several months but the
problem was when she came back reporters
asked her what she had missed and she
said I've been here I've been voting she
seemed very confused so there were a lot
of uh calls for her to possibly step
down but now she has passed at the age
of 90 leaving behind quite a legacy as
you mentioned the longest serving woman
to ever serve in the Senate the first
woman to ever serve as the head of the
Senate intelligence committee and it's
hard to overstate just how important
that position is that person is becomes
a member of What's called the gang of
eight so whenever anything happens when
it comes to the intelligence Community
the president makes sure that the gang
of eight is briefed so that's the checks
and balances on the president uh she had
a very impactful career in the Senate uh
especially when it comes to guns she
became uh mayor of San Francisco after
an assassination which she witnessed and
she said that forever scarred her and so
she introduced and passed uh the
military assault uh style weapons ban
that was in place from 1994 to 2004 and
it was incredibly effective we saw mass
shootings go down in that time when New
Town Connecticut on 20 children and six
uh Educators were killed in Connecticut
she tried to reinstate that uh assault
weapons Bann and failed after Furious
Republican opposition uh the other thing
that she will be remembered for is the
fact that we know what the CIA did to
torture people from Afghanistan and Iraq
that was her office she told her
staffers because of her position where
she had access to all that class
classified information to find the
information they came up with a report
she fought to get it Declassified that's
why we know about the black sites and
the horrific torture that the CIA misled
the White House and Congress about so at
the age of 90 Dian Feinstein leaving
behind quite the Legacy controversial at
the end but uh really for the one of the
first women in the Senate she was an
incredibly impactful lawmaker okay thank
you so much Petty that is petty Khan for
us in Washington DC